Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Megan's laughing already,
because you could tell it's Friday.
Today, we're going to start on just
a couple of lectures that are,
could be labeled other
stuff you should know.
It's just things that come along in
Computer Vision that are, are relevant.
Some of them are very old,
some of them are new.
Some of them seem trivial so
we don't even teach about them normally.
And yet if you don't know about them,
you're totally mystified when
somebody talks to you about them.
And what we're going to talk about
today is a little bit about color.
Now, I had to wrestle a little bit with
exactly how to do this because my own
background color really came
through psychophysics psychologies.
My, my degree was in brain and
cognitive sciences.
So and I think of color as a
psychophysical or perceptual phenomena.
That is when you see this thing and
you say, oh, that's a light blue shirt.
That's actually not a physics statement,
it's a psychophysics statement.
So I'm actually going to start there.
We're going to talk about just a little
bit about, actually an, anatomy.
And then we'll move on to a little
bit of computational elements having
to do with color.
So and also in a few more lessons,
you're going to see some, just a few
of these slides and discussions again,
because we're going to talk
about the humans vision system.
But I need to just talk about
a little bit of it now, and
in particular,
I have to talk about your retina.
Well, and my retina,
and everybody's retina.